قال مستشار للامن القومي الامريكي ان
بلاده لا ترى اي تغير في الموقف النووي
الروسي واضاف في لقاء مع قناه سي ان
الامريكيه نواشنطن تحافظ على خطوط اتصال
مع روسيا لمنع رفع التصعيد على هذا
المستوى
ما يمكنني التحدث عنه هو ما نراه ولا نرى
اي تغيير في الموقف النووي لروسيا لم نقم
باي تغييرات في وضعنا النووي ايضا لذلك
نحن يقظون باستمرار ونحتفظ ايضا بقنوات
منتظمه مع الحكومه الروسيه حتى نتمكن من
التحدث معهم بشان مخاطر هذا التصعيد وايضا
للتعبير عن خطوره عواقب استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه لكن من وجهه نظرنا حتى الان لا
نرى اي تحركات في القوات النوويه الروسيه
تقودنا الى الاعتقاد بان شيئا ما قد تغير
بشكل اساسي عما سارت عليه الامور العمل
الماضي